hey guys it's Justine and today is a
very exciting day I don't want to talk
too well because I don't want my dog to
hear but we're having his fourth
Adoption Day birthday today his adoption
day was actually in August but I've been
traveling a lot so I'm finally home and
we're gonna have a celebration today
Jana's upstairs preparing some of our
decorations but first we have to wrap
some of his gifts the main gift is from
Bissell
a huge thank you to Bissell for
sponsoring this video this was designed
by bristles pet parent engineers and it
was designed to be Bissell's best pet
hair cleanup system what's also great
about this is Bissell is donating twenty
five dollars for every purchase of one
of these two their bissell pet
foundation this makes me so happy
because we got Maddy at a shelter the
first year of his life was so crazy
because he had so many allergies and so
many problems but now he's growing up to
be a beautiful boy and now we're
celebrating with him Jenna we got a wrap
his presents before he sees what we're
doing oh oh my gosh this is so exciting
I know so we're gonna let him just make
the biggest mess that he wants and we
gonna clean it all up so the theme of
Maddie's party is camo when I went to
the party store I could not believe all
the camel things as they happen
I saw him they also had ping-pong balls
Maddie loves ping pong balls what's
great about this hat is that it's for
dogs there's also a dog toy cool um
these are some flowers that Edie
actually got for Maddie so we're gonna
wrap those up for him because I have a
chance to go to a pet store I also got
his pinata
which we're gonna fill up with food he's
so gentle he's actually gonna like the
tag that says $19.99 so there's actual
honestly this was so expensive explain
oh I also got some wrapping paper which
- I know I
oh look you bought new wrapping paper
and find the wrapping paper I don't know
where he put it still into the couch you
got tape so birthday candles we're also
gonna want pizza cuz Maddy likes pizza
crusts
okay Jenna likes pizza crusts so I put
all these things in my camera purse
oh my gosh what are you done we thought
the fatty we've got all kinds of stuff
party poppers we've got army men we've
got whistles oh he loves taking drinks
out of a cup I need to post mates a cake
right now
hold on all right let's wrap this icon
fete I powered a cordless vacuum is
equipped with convenient focus features
designed specifically for homes with
pets one of my favorite things is the
tangle free brush rule it has a
removable dirt bin for easy emptying a
smart seal allergen system that helps
trap dust and allergens inside the
vacuum they're specialized pet tools to
powerfully clean pet hair from all sorts
of nooks and crannies there's three
cleaning modes to work on any floor type
there's a swivel steering for easy
maneuvering around furniture it also
charges quickly on a wall mount which
allows for an organized storage solution
it allows for 50 minutes of cordless
cleaning depending upon mode and
attachments and it also has convenient
options to use as a stick vacuum or a
hand vacuum with a motorized turbo brush
tool like Go Daddy that's bad all right
this is a big box where's the tissue
paper the gift you really wants is just
a tissue paper
I don't really entice him which I put
these little flowers in there too
yeah entice him okay why don't you get
started on then oh yeah we're having a
separations his gifts I got a whistle
for us to wear I got three for all three
of us this is 44 cents will it go away
yes oh well wait a minute
what here this place is nicely down
don't look at the secret its Gorilla
Tape dude thick here let me get some
scissors for you thick boy tape oh my
gosh Matty's party is here you got a
ring you don't think knows we're setting
up his birthday - no honey I think
there's a squirrel outside child is gone
[Music]
for Matt it smells good we go take it
oh he's happy Matty already has a lot of
toys so I didn't want to buy him any
more toys are basically gonna re get
just mu has previously purchased toys
this is one of his favorites we're going
to wrap anything pawn the ball if you
look to this favorite
[Music]
not yet but look I'll give you sneak
peek so we need to have Maddy unbox his
first gift first so huge thank you again
to Bissell for sponsoring this video we
need to give Maddie as a new icon pet
vacuum he's like I want to vacuum Wow oh
there are so many accessories this is a
gift from mommy dude this is a nice
color
you guys gentle looks about you mmm oh
I'm gonna have fun with this oh wait I'm
gonna need my pants to be vacuumed
[Music]
what are you doing daddy
away
oh my gosh it's gone
all right well the pizza should be here
soon associate his cake and then we can
start celebrating do you want a vacuum a
little like any true okay I mean it
still has battery but I feel like we
should charge it up to finish setting up
for the party are you sitting okay good
what do you want it you want the vacuum
[Music]
let's finish setting up the pizza should
be here his cake should be here soon
actually it's a cake for us but it's
okay thank you
Thanks Oh Oh surprise thank you back up
Manny back up you've got pizza and we've
got cake exciting it's for your party
Justine pizza's here it's a little small
this was supposed to be a big pizza oh
that looks good Mady foods here it's a
special day I'm a pizza no well hold on
wait a minute this is not all for you
glad eat your pizza please break it for
you because you don't have a lot of
teeth
oh oh okay with this piece of bread here
so much anything with that oh wow
sit sit Pizza yeah yummy cake cake oh
happy Adoption Day Madi oh my gosh this
is this is a cake for us not having
unfortunately oh yeah Maddy
you're gonna be living the good life
happy birthday to Maddy
hey man look here's your cake nice it's
it night who's a good boy
oh no his flame is flickered out okay I
had to stack another candle on top of
the candle this is for taking pictures
of the wall and it melted Maddy I'm
gonna blow your candle out for you ready
yummy Maddy yummy oh gosh now we open
presents
Maddy we have some presents for you here
what could ever possibly look at this
this is from Edie turn egg that's from
the head look what the year as if that
wasn't enough what's in there magic it
in but you gotta get in there
all our toys oh he's so confused right I
know what you want Maddy this is gonna
be a good toy okay
sit okay Freddie which hand good boy
oh he saw that's a ping-pong ball
wrapped in tissue paper so I have to go
supervise everything I just gave him
no look how much fun my face is paper
[Applause]
[Music]
okay first try ready alright fun should
we let it run around outside now I think
there's a squirtle out here
[Music]
oh boy
I think that Maddie had a good time I
had a good time but there's bread and
pizza crust everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
you need to vacuum underneath this couch
there's fuzzies everywhere
[Music]
oh forget these corners
[Applause]
[Music]
he's doing over here we're exhausted
from the party oh my goodness I was just
resting well thank you guys for coming
to the party thank you I guess I could
move up to my couch oh and thank you
guys so much for watching and coming to
Mattie's Adoption Day party if you guys
are looking for a pet definitely choose
adoption over shopping or breeders Maddy
has been such a joy in mine and Jenna's
life as you guys can tell from all the
things that we post on Instagram if you
want to follow Maddie go check him out
at DJ mini Matt Cavallo Jenna Jenna is
Eric and a huge thank you to Bissell
response in this video you wanna get
more information about the icon pet by
Bissell check out icon pet cordless calm
and I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]